il ya un manque cruel de stratégie
aujourd'hui la politique je pense que
mon costard cravate ou au tailleur vous
pouvez dire motiver les gens à agir
le plus dur nous y sommes le plus dur
nous y sommes pour quelques mois encore
nous vivons et cela pas simplement
depuis cet été ces dernières années au
fond la fin de ce qui pouvait apparaître
comme une abondance savez il va y avoir
un décret qui va interdire l'allumage
des vitrines des magasins entre 1h et 6h
du matin plan de rationnement c'est
celui qui nous évitera justement les
coupures
la question qui m'a été posée c'est ce
que vous avez couvrir la totalité des
dépenses d'inflation pour toutes les
familles françaises dans la durée la
réponse elle doit être honnête la
réponse est non il ya cette notion
évidente de calibration de
contextualisations ça on en parle tout
ans et c'est la manière dont on va
imaginer diffuser le message en relation
aux enjeux concernés par le message qui
est un manque cruel de stratégie de
stratégies liées à cette
contextualisations aujourd'hui si je
dois parler à mon peuple de sobriété si
je dois parler mon peuple d'économies
est il préférable que je le fasse en
costard cravate dans une salle dont les
moulures sont toutes dorées ou est il
préférable que je le fasse dans un
contexte plus approprié si nous faisons
si nous épargnons 10 % de notre
consommation énergétique tous
globalement on peut faire face même un
hiver rigoureux difficile nous
demanderons aux français de s'inscrire
dans cette dynamique là à la fois pour
cet hiver je le redis à la fois pour
notre planète dans un discours public la
proportionnalité elle est fondamentale
on est un pas un feu de forêt avec un
verre d'eau tout comme on ne tue pas un
poussin avec un lance-roquettes ça c'est
les bases de la proportionnalité alors
maintenant la question c'est à voir est
ce que vous ressentez une envie d'agir
lorsque vous écoutez la politique non
justement parce que il y a un mauvais
calibrage de cette proportionnalité
aujourd'hui la politique pense que en
costard cravate ou au tailleur vous
pouvez dire motiver les gens à agir on
est de nouveau dans quelque chose de
très plat on est dans quelque chose qui
goûte vraiment comme un verre d'eau
tiède et ça je pense que ça ne
fonctionne plus l'heure n'est plus à
attendre l'heure n'est plus aux demi
mesures
l'heure n'est plus au chacun pour soi
l'heure est à la responsabilité
collective
elisabeth bornes vous prenez son
discours de politique générale devant
l'assemblée qui c'est qui s'est tenue il
ya quelques semaines nous avions une
elisabeth bornes beaucoup plus à l'aise
dans le contexte avec une rhétorique
plus dur une rhétorique plus sèches une
rhétorique d'une première ministre
fraîchement élu aujourd'hui si on prend
le discours d avec born cette première
ministre devant le medef donc un
discours récent là encore on retombe
dans une elisabeth bornes qui est en
décalage total entre les enjeux liés au
contexte et la manière de faire état
entreprises collectivités citoyens
chacun doit prendre sa part
la situation l'exigent c'est l'unique
moyen pour réussir
c'est aussi une occasion historique pour
vivre mieux et pour les entrepreneurs
que vous êtes ce défi doit être une
opportunité
lorsque vous avez des politiciennes des
politiciens qui vous parle d'un problème
grave par exemple il y a plusieurs
manières d'en parler et là il ya ce
qu'on appelle le mimétisme vocal
mimétisme vocale c'est quoi c'est de
venir utiliser sa voix ses sonorités
pour mimer les mots que nous sommes en
train de transmettre si je vous parle
aujourd'hui d'un immense problème ce
n'est pas la même chose que s'ils vous
parle d'un immense problème et ça on ne
le perçoit n'avons qu'une seule voix la
baisse de la consommation d'énergie
cette baisse je vous propose que nous
n'aurons nous l'organisions ensemble
si nous ne le faisons pas si chacun ne
prend pas sa part des coupures brutales
de gaz pourrait avoir lieu du jour au
lendemain avec des graves conséquences
économiques et sociales
alors notre première urgence c'est
d'arrêter dès maintenant toutes les
consommations d'énergie qui ne sont pas
indispensables
comme si finalement les émetteurs de
messager terre était complètement
inhabitée inhabitée des enjeux qui sont
ceux qui sont les nôtres aujourd'hui et
donc il y à ces enjeux qui doivent
habiter l'émetteur du message il est
important de préciser que la
communication est composé de deux
tiroirs vous avez le tiroir de la
conviction et le tiroir de la persuasion
le tiroir de la conviction c'est
utiliser des mécanismes pour faire un
travail sur l'opinion du public
l'opinion du public c'est simplement se
demander est il d'accord ou non avec ce
que je dis et ça aujourd'hui je crois
que tout le monde est d'accord sur les
enjeux climatiques tout le monde à la à
la conscience des enjeux climatiques
mais si vous vous arrêtez à l'art de
convaincre vous ressembler à une page
wikipédia vous ressemblez un
dictionnaire c'est absolument pas sexy
il faut se poser la question de la
persuasion la persuasion sait comment
mettront mouvement mon public et c'est
là où interviennent les émotions comment
je peux moins susciter des émotions
auprès de mon audience pour lui donner
envie d'agir avec et pour nous pour la
cause qui nous unit mais maintenant il
faut passer à la vitesse supérieure il
faut demander aux gens de s'engager et
il faut véhiculer les émotions et ça la
politique a énormément peine